let's talk about the taliban
they've been fighting the government and
its allies in afghanistan for 20 years
today they seem stronger than ever the
taliban have adapted their tactics
they've gotten more brutal and now the
americans are going home
it's time to end the forever war biden
wants his troops out by september 11th
and that could strengthen the taliban
even more
so who exactly are the taliban how is it
that they have so much power
and why are people worried they'll take
over afghanistan again
to understand the taliban you need to
know what happened in afghanistan in the
1980s
afghan guerrillas called the mujahideen
fought a soviet occupation for nine
years
they even got money and weapons from the
cia
in 1989 the soviets pulled out and the
next few years were pretty chaotic
by 1992 there was a full-blown civil war
with tribal leaders fighting for power
two years later a militia called the
taliban started getting attention
many of its members had studied in
conservative religious schools in
afghanistan
and across the border in pakistan and
some of them had also fought as
mujahideen
and they had their own plans for the
country
[Music]
the people were so frustrated with this
lawlessness
and the taliban came marching along from
kandar to city
city to city saying we're gonna make
the cities safe for you again by 1996
the taliban had seized the capital
they declared afghanistan an islamic
emirate and started imposing their own
strict interpretation of islamic law
they were like you can't watch movies
you can't listen to music women
can't go to school and other than
doctors they can't go to work
you have to wear certain type of clothes
you have to have a certain kind of beard
you know it just became more and more
restrictive
then 9 11 happened the u.s was after al
qaeda's leader osama bin laden who was
hiding out in afghanistan with the
taliban's help the taliban said they
wanted proof he was behind the attack
and when they refused to hand him over
immediately the americans invaded
the taliban will pay a price
[Applause]
within a couple of months the taliban
were forced out of power and afghanistan
got a new interim government
three years later it got a new
constitution and mohammed karzai was
elected president
while that was going on the taliban had
regrouped
they wanted foreigners out and they
wanted back in
what followed were years of devastating
conflict
and it's still going on more than 40 000
afghan civilians killed at least 64 000
afghan military and police
and more than 3 500 international
soldiers dead
the u.s alone has spent almost a
trillion dollars on the war
and reconstruction projects and after
all that
afghanistan is still deeply unstable and
the taliban
are still a force to reckon with they're
an insurgency
fighting international occupation as
they see it
they're fighting an illegitimate
government in kabul as they see it
and they're a voice of resistance to as
they see it
return afghanistan to a more pure
islamic society
[Music]
today the taliban have as many as 85 000
full-time fighters and training camps
across the country
and the area they control has been
growing
right now the taliban control one-fifth
of afghan districts
on top of that half of all districts are
considered contested which means the
taliban have a strong presence in many
of those places too
and they control parts of some major
highways whoever controls the roads in
afghanistan
you know pretty much controls the
country they've managed to
basically give people the sense that you
know wherever you go
you'll have to deal with the taliban
they're also well organized the
taliban's leader is haiba tala
akunsada he heads a council that
oversees about a dozen commissions in
charge of things like finance
health and education below them are
local officials in charge of everyday
services
so in a way the taliban have set up a
parallel state
they even run their own courts which
can't be pretty popular among afghans
justice has been a huge gap in
afghanistan
and where the state courts have failed
these sharia courts
are able to come in to communities who
may even be reticent to
to support the taliban but they offer
justice
all that control has also made them rich
according to taliban members
and a u.n committee they make close to
one and a half billion dollars a year
they've always made a lot of money from
growing opium poppies and the drug trade
but they found even more ways to
generate income last year they made
millions from mining and trading
minerals and even producing
methamphetamine
they also have their own tax collection
system and receive funding from abroad
although suspected sources like pakistan
and iran deny it
over the years the international
community has tried to get the taliban
and the afghan government talking
or at least to talk about talking there
was even a meeting in the maldives at
one point
and during a brief eid ceasefire in 2018
taliban and afghan soldiers were seen
mingling in kabul
even praying together but overall peace
negotiations
haven't achieved much the ghanaian
government has been incredibly
antagonistic and sees the taliban as a
real existential threat to
everything that they represent the
taliban have been quite a damage on
their demand
that they want the re-establishment of
their
regime that was uh toppled by the u.s
intervention
the question now is what will happen
when the roughly 10 000
u.s and nato soldiers leave will the
afghan government be able to survive
and what will the taliban do
[Music]
well the prospects for peace and
stability aren't looking great
even while peace talks have been going
on almost 1
800 afghan civilians have been killed or
injured in the first
three months of this year that's almost
30 percent more than last year
there's also been a wave of
assassinations that people blame on the
taliban
targeted killings continue civilian
government workers employees but also
activists and journalists it's to
make people feel less and less safe less
and less secure
to sort of send back the message
repeatedly
that your government is not protecting
you
afghans are already asking themselves
what life might be like
the taliban take over again will they
rip up the constitution
which protects basic human rights will
women be able to travel without a male
guardian
will women be able to be judges will a
woman be able to run for president there
is a lot
that is ambiguous and unknown in a new
york times op-ed the taliban
tried to clear things up saying they
want to build an islamic system where
the rights of women that are granted by
islam from the right to education
to the right to work are protected and
right now there are some places under
taliban control where girls
are in school but not everywhere it's
really localized
i mean some areas we know that they're
the local commanders have um
are a bit more flexible when it comes to
women's education and some areas they
are not at
all so how much support is there for the
taliban well according to a major public
opinion study done in 2019
85 of people said they had no sympathy
for them
i've traveled to a large proportion of
this country
the vast majority of people i speak to
don't have a favorable view of the
taliban
people may not like them but the taliban
know what they want
and they've shown that they're in it for
the long haul so far
their strategy seems to have worked
[Music]
al jazeera is always monitoring the
situation in afghanistan and the
negotiations here in doha
so check out our website for the latest
and youtube for reports from our
correspondents on the ground
i'll see you next week
you